Joel it's such a great pleasure to be
speaking with you today about your new
book the foundation a great American
secret how private wealth is changing
the world
great title by the way and I think it's
it's quite true we're at a pivotal
turning point it seems to me in the
history of foundations foundations are
much more visible I think than they have
been in the past we have constant news
stories about the Gates Foundation and
the things that they're doing in Africa
we have the warren buffett's magnificent
gift to the Gates Foundation 31 billion
dollars and yet despite all that
publicity your book says and I think
it's true that this foundations are a
great American secret and that secret it
seems to me is double edged the public
doesn't know about foundations and
foundations are quite secretive tell us
about this great American secret the
reason I wrote the book is that I
believe the public deserves to know what
foundations do and that foundations
deserve to have the public know what
they do given the fact that foundations
are messing around in every lots of
things dealing with public public
supported programs public education
welfare the environment health all of
those things the public has a right to
know what foundations are doing but more
than that if the public doesn't know
exactly what foundations are doing those
people who want to start programs of
their own really don't have any basis on
which to make a judgment about what
works what doesn't work how it works why
it doesn't work and that really is the
nature of the secret the secret I called
it a secret for two reasons one because
foundations really don't tell very much
about what they're doing and secondly
because of the fact that the public
doesn't know anything about foundations
a surveys show that if you ask the
public what what the foundation is the
most recent survey asked showed I saw
revealed that only 12% of the public
what a foundation could name a
foundation that's just naming a
foundation that doesn't have anything to
do with naming what the foundation does
and so what should the public know
general I think the public really should
know when about foundation failures for
example it's you know it's inconceivable
impossible that if that with the 30-some
billion dollars that a foundation spends
every year that all the foundation spent
every year that they don't make anything
they don't have any failures and yet for
the when I wrote the book I could
document only four or five publicly
acknowledged failures by foundations
that's just unbelievable what that means
is that not only on foundation is not
talking about their failures but why
should people believe what they say
about their successes if they don't talk
about their failures because people are
going to say well if they don't talk
about their failures there must be some
things wrong there and some of these
things like claiming as successes really
weren't successes now do you think
people understand Joel you know what is
the foundation maybe we ought to start
there
why why are they important in the
American polyarchy a term that you use
they're very important because they
empower individuals with widely varying
points of view to express their values
in ways that affect the larger sphere so
that you've got lots of different ways
of solving the problem of public
problems of public education if you've
got many different people working in
there now what I say in the book is that
that you've given the fact that America
has a nonprofit sector which is most
people would say who think about this
thing the envy of the world we got at
this point according to the most recent
count more than a million 501 C 3
charitable nonprofits that doesn't
include most of the churches and
religious organizations which probably
is another 300 to 350,000 entities so
you're up to 1.3 million charitable
organizations plus the non-charitable
not-for-profit organizations that is the
the the packs and a variety of other
mutual benefit organization
so you've got a nonprofit sector with
1.9 million organizations spending
according to the IRS as most recent
figures somewhere in excess of a
trillion dollars it's probably close to
a 1.5 trillion dollars one point four
trillion dollars you put that against
the federal government for example which
you've got a federal budget this year of
2.8 trillion dollars in a national
economy of 14 trillion dollars you think
about that's a very significant
proportion of what the federal
government is spending so it's important
that the public understand that the
nonprofit sector is important the
nonprofit sector the venture capital
that enables the nonprofit sector to be
creative original pioneering in its
solutions is in large part the work of
foundations the foundations really are
the kernel of that social venture
capital that powers the nonprofit sector
and I think it's extremely important
that that we have as many different
points of view as possible represented
in that nonprofit sector through
foundations so I'm I'm a great advocate
of nonprofits of foundations as a as the
source of a lot of that energy and money
that makes it all happen you're
obviously very passionate about the
topic and you care your care quite a bit
about foundations and what they're doing
and about civil society in America but
you're also critical and I think that
your criticisms come from the heart and
I'm wondering you know how would you how
would you tell us about the shortcomings
of foundations I would say that that I
can't I don't I can't really explain
well why foundations aren't more
forthcoming about what they do I think
it has to do with a lot of different
things I think it has to do in part
because foundations would prefer not to
have people second-guess their decisions
I think in some cases they're not sure
that they made the right to
Asians I think in some cases it's really
a question of it's just easier for
organizations to operate if they don't
have anybody looking over their
shoulders the problem is that if people
aren't looking over the shoulders of
foundations they're the foundations
themselves cannot possibly be doing as
good a job as they would otherwise do we
all benefit from criticism we all
benefit from constructive criticism as
well as destructive criticism we all
benefit with people on the outside who
aren't involved in what we do are
looking at us that's part of competition
that that powers the for-profit sector
and there really isn't any competition
that comes to bear all the on the
decision-making of foundations there
really isn't any external criticism
that's and I think it's extremely
important for them in order for
foundations to perform their mission in
a more effective fashion if they have
that outside criticism there's the
larger issue if you if you if you
believe that the nonprofit sector ought
to be out to have many different ways of
solving problems then you want the
foundations to be open about what
they're doing so that people can have
blueprints of what they've done so they
can replicate them you know the glory of
the natural sciences the Medical
Sciences for example is everything that
everybody does with an experiment is
public and when they do an experiment
they do it they try something it doesn't
work everybody knows that they don't
repeat the error or they don't repeat
the error in the same way we don't have
in the social sector with foundations we
don't have that basic information that
is required for the nonprofit sector to
build on mistakes that people have made
bit to improve on models the other that
people have made the information just
isn't there I think I I've mentioned
from time to time they there's a
wonderful guy by the name of John Abele
who started a foundation and before he
started it because it's called the
Argosy foundation he called me up and he
said we're about to start a large
foundation and we are interested in
education we're interested in technology
were interested in three or four
things and I'd like to know where I can
go to find out what foundations have
done with what consequences and I
laughed and I said John there isn't any
such place foundations don't tell you
about those things you have to dig at it
in order to find it and that's not the
way it should be
let's get back to the donors the people
who set up these foundations and because
I think maybe this the secrecy or this
lack of transparency as you say in the
book might have something to do with how
people approach their philanthropy you
have inspiring case studies of wonderful
things and and I would say a part of the
history of the United States which is
just completely missing in a way one can
find a lot in your case studies here but
donors give for lots of different
reasons and you take on this question in
your book some are instrumental which is
you know creating change and others are
expressive why could that be important
as we talk about foundations it's very
important because the donor leaves an
imprint on the foundations that he or
she created the foundations reflect the
values of the donor by and large
although some critics of foundations say
that they don't reflect the values
enough but they but they by and large do
reflect the values and styles of the
donors and many people who with wealth
really don't want to they're they're
very different about letting people know
that they've got money they're very
different about the spending of the
money that's why the estimate is
something like 10 percent of all of the
major individual gifts are given
anonymously because people that's some
part of it is self protective they don't
want people to know they got money so
that people won't come to them and ask
them for money but I think a lot of it
has to do with a certain style of a
donor where the donor really doesn't
want to brag about it the donor is in
the end in the foundation world
everybody says and it's true that well
we don't want to take credit for things
that we do because we really don't do it
all we do is empower others to do it all
of our money goes to nonprofit
organizations with leaders and with
staff and with volunteers
they're the ones who really do the work
we don't do the work all we do is just
provide the means for them to do the
work so it's sort of long for us to take
credit about what they do and I
understand that I buy that but many
initiatives of foundations today or
foundation and Foundation initiated
project in fact if you look at the large
foundations most of them are foundation
initiated projects where they really
orchestrated the idea from the beginning
picked people to carry the ideas out and
they bear some responsibility for
therefore the judgments that they made
as to whether something worked or didn't
work and the people they selected in the
architecture of the initiative and so on
and I think it it it's very difficult
for me to accept the view that become
that that simply because foundations
exist and because the donors would have
preferred to remain below the radar in
these gifts that that's appropriate for
us given the advanced state of the
nonprofit sector and the advanced state
of philanthropy as has carried out by
foundations today so that leads you to
some suggestions about foundation
strategy and about how foundations can
be more effective based on your case
studies you have a hundred of them that
you've looked at 100 instances of
foundation programs and I think these
are really interesting and then twelve
are profiled in the book so talk to me a
little bit about the strategies that you
uncovered in the in the twelve cases and
it in the hundred cases actually there
are many different strategies that
foundations use to accomplish their
objectives I talked about human resource
development strategies that's one of the
largest probably in the oldest that is
things like scholarships fellowships
where they're building human resources
for the society most foundations of any
age have done this forever we hear about
some of the more unusual ones such as
the MacArthur Genius Awards there but
many foundations have fellowships for
PhD candidates many foundations have
scholarships for
graduates many foundations the Freeman
foundation has a very ambitious program
to provide scholarships for students of
East East Asian Studies and they claim
and as far as I can tell accurately that
they've educated about their
scholarships have educated some 20% of
all of the students who studied East
Asian subject matter in American
colleges and universities so Human
Resource Development is one particular
strategy that which can be carried out
in a number of different ways another
strategy that some foundations have used
is is a strategy of knowledge
development rather than rather than
training human resources people it's
developing new ideas about how to solve
problems and I would say that's probably
the second largest group of foundation
programs and they're a clear focus on
strategic efforts to develop new
knowledge that's what all the medicals
medical research foundations do but it's
also what a lot of the foundations that
focus on social sector problems do there
are there are strategies that
foundations use in building models for
example the number of foundations carry
out their missions by building a model
letting it work for a few years often
not long enough and then hoping that
others will pick it up and then they'll
go on to some other model building but
there our strategy of giving prizes for
example of for recognizing distinction
or incenting people to discover whatever
it is that the foundation wants to do so
the wide range of strategies that
foundations use the relationship between
a strategy and whether it accomplishes
anything is where effectiveness comes in
and a number you know the this to be
strategic means to focus it means to to
be clear about what you want to
accomplish to go about it in a an
orderly fashion
it really does go back to what Andrew
Carnegie and
Rockefeller referred to as scientific
management it is thinking in a in a
common-sense way what is it I'm trying
to accomplish what what is the
background the context in which I'm
going to try to accomplish this problem
why is it the problem doesn't solve
itself what's keeping it from being
solved what what actors do I need to
orchestrate in order to get it done how
am I going to know along the way whether
it's working or not and how am I going
to know when it's finished if it did
work that's being self the articulating
self-conscious about the steps that need
to go in to strategy a lot of due
diligence is really is essential to be
effective in in strategic initiatives
and foundations say in the book that
scientific management is kind of
characteristics of an earlier period in
foundation giving but it has fallen into
disfavor and I wonder if you elaborate
on that
well it's only did this favor during
most of the middle of the 20th century
in the sense that just as I think many
people in in academia were suspicious of
of value-free
social science and came to see
everything as a test of values rather
than of scientific method the same thing
I think happened in foundations but
we've returned to it if you look at
what's going on now in the field of
venture philanthropy social enterprise
that really is a clear return to the
scientific management philosophy about
about philanthropy it is to say that you
know we want to know just as I laid it
out a minute ago we want to know we want
to be clear about what we're trying to
do we want to be clear about how we go
about doing it you want to be clear
about knowing that we're making progress
and we want to be clear about knowing
that it's done when it's done and so
we've now really moved back to that that
same approach though it's not called
scientific management it's not very
different
what Andrew Carnegie did for example
early on there there's a critique of
course of professional over
professionalization
in the foundation world how would you
respond to that critique I think that
there is no I have no clear point of
view about what kinds of people make the
best foundation officers because some of
the best foundation officers both CEOs
and program officers were not
specialists and they're not scientists
and they're not management people
they're people with extraordinary
instinctive judgment about quality about
people with promise about ideas the
sense of timing a sense that a problem
is ripe to be solved a sense that this
person whom they're thinking about is
the right person to lead that effort but
it is also true that if you're thinking
if you think about some of the more
technical areas for example in
scientific research or in in risk in in
efforts that require demonstration
programs of one sort or another you need
people with technical expertise in order
to do it so you know I'm I'm agnostic
when it comes to any particular kind of
program officer or CEO being the best
person but I do believe that every
foundation that deals in certain areas
has to have some specialists in there
who are expert in the subject matter
area as well as in the way you go about
analyzing it is it fair to say though
that your critique really goes to or
your recommendations really go to the
staffed foundations the small proportion
of foundations that have staff because
as we both know most of the foundation
world is unstaffed run by volunteers yes
and we think that they're probably what
2,500 2,000 independent foundations that
have any staff and many of those only
have one to three staff persons so how
does a small foundation fit into your
analysis well the lesson from the cases
is pretty clear if you want to
accomplish an objective a defined
objective then you need to be strategic
and that's true whether you're a big
foundation with lots of staff or a small
family foundation that is unstaffed
you need I've worked don't occasionally
work with individual family foundation
some of which are unstaffed and it
requires members of a family to get
together and agree on what they want to
give and what they want to accomplish
most of the most of the smaller
foundations really operate as sort of
family charities either by the family
charities by the donor and they give to
many different things some of them tried
to get the benefits of focus by
narrowing their catchment areas to a
particular city where they all lived or
grew up or where the family fortune was
made or a particular county or a
particular state and that provides a
kind of focus as well but the truth is
that that the message of the book is
focus if you want to achieve something
and that applies across the board it
applies especially to the large
foundations the twenty five hundred or
so foundations with most of the money
most of the assets and most in giving
away most of the money because given the
fact that the taxpayers have some
interest in this because they
facilitated the creation of the
foundations in the first place
by providing a tax deduction for gifts
to establish the foundation so that that
money was untaxed that went into it if
it was appreciated and they also have an
interest in it because they don't they
don't pay any foundations don't pay any
taxes so there's an the public has an
interest in seeing that that and the
money in the foundations it's now you
know the the assets of foundations at
this point or somewhere north of half a
trillion dollars they're spending
somewhere between around thirty to
thirty to thirty three billion dollars a
year public has an interest in seeing
that that money is spent to maximal
social effect that's very different from
what the small and staff family group
foundations do where they can afford to
do what interests them it's their money
and it mostly though the public has an
interest in it and if they want to spend
it on the arts or they want to spend it
on on particularly apropos Ria's Ruth
Lillie did or or protecting cats and
dogs those are all important things in a
society and if
we'll care about them and they made
money they ought to be able to spend
them on those things so when we talk
about effectiveness and stewardship and
accountability it applies to all
foundations but the effectiveness high
impact you say in the book that really
applies to the larger foundations where
we expect them with that large amount of
money to be using that money effectively
it does but it also it also applies to
the Community Foundation's many of which
are small the Community Foundation in
Raleigh Durham Chapel Hill has 100
million dollars I mean that's large by
some standards but compared to the big
private foundations it's not it's not
large and that the Community
Foundation's have whatever their size
they have an obligation to be effective
too because they exist for the purpose
of benefiting improve their communities
though whatever their catchment area
happens to be so it applies clearly to
them as well as to the large private
foundations but it does apply really to
staffed foundations because because the
these unstaffed foundations do not have
the due diligence capacity they do not
have the central point of of a CEO or a
chief program officer through which
through whom all of the views and values
of the members of the board mainly the
donors can act they don't have a head
for themselves about corporate
foundations you don't talk much about
them in the book I don't talk about
corporate foundations in large part
because that's really a separate area
most the corporate foundations really
are exist for in part for the purposes
of the interests of the corporation
and they're how much they the corporate
foundations spend typically depends on
the profits the free of the corporation
the preceding year and corporations
typically spend money on things that
benefit the public perception of the
corporations there are lots of different
mixed motives there that really cut
against the notion of a single criterion
for effectiveness and what the
foundations do there
the large foundations for example give
money all over give money give money all
over the country they give money where
they've got facilities they give they
frequently will delegate to the local
look the officials responsible for the
local units this discretion about what
they spend a big chunk of what fat of
corporate foundations to give and
corporations is in matching funds for
them matching employee contributions to
principally to educational institutions
or to others so I didn't cover them in
the book because it seemed to me they
were just a totally different character
than the probably founder it would seem
that they would have the same
imperatives though to be effective to
steward their resources and to be
accountable because after all that is
also tax-deductible money I agree with
that that they should but but the way
you solve that problem struck me as
being different from the way the problem
is solved with respect to the private
foundations of the community foundations
let's talk a little bit about
accountability actually we've been
talking about accountability in one form
or another for most of our conversations
but you say that foundation should be
held to high standards and that they
should be accountable this is part of
the mission part of the driving force
because of the way that they're set up
and I wonder if there's anything more
you wanted to say about accountability
it's on everybody's lips these days
foundations need to be more accountable
do you see another angle to that well
I'll say two things about it I think
that it is important for foundations to
take the initiative to satisfy their own
accountability problems I would hate to
see government at any level really
intruding itself to enforce
accountability more than beyond the
range of accountability to the
requirements of the letter of the law
with respect to what convey what
foundations can spend money on legally
501 C 3 s basically I would not I would
like not to see that the government get
into the accountability arena in any
significant way
substantively about the kinds of things
that foundations do that's where I want
foundations to take the initiative
themselves and and to adopt more
openness with respect to what they do
along the lines that we were talking
about earlier you say I define
accountability in the book really as a
as an imperative to let open up the
windows and the doors and let the public
see what you're doing let people in the
nonprofit sectors see what you're doing
let's get more information out there and
there's some very good initiatives that
have begun by foundations where
foundations of some foundations for
example the Wallace foundation the
Packard Foundation both have now adopted
the practice of hiring independent
consultants at the time they make the
grant and saying we want you to evaluate
this grant from the this initiative from
the beginning to the end we give you
free license to publish whatever you
want to publish and and that kind of
self confidence in what they're doing
and in letting the chips fall where they
may
strikes me is very giving the public a
very good reason for saying well that
foundation is trying to do the right
thing and I think that many foundations
ought to follow in the recommendations
in the book I made getting foundations
to establish some criteria of Trance of
transparency and then creating a group
of foundations that would say to other
foundations look we think you ought to
be doing this whatever this happens to
be different ways of doing it and we're
going to rank the foundations or give
them a seal of transport of transparency
so that the public can see which ones
are transparent in which ones are
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with Joel Fleischman and
Elizabeth Boras in a moment
last February art buchwald checked into
a Washington DC hospice expecting to
live only three weeks over the next 11
months he resumed his syndicated columns
wrote a book and spent the summer on
Martha's Vineyard the Pulitzer
prize-winning humorist died Wednesday at
the age of 81
tonight on book TV an encore
presentation of his December book talk
in Washington DC Art Buchwald too soon
to say goodbye 11:15 p.m. Eastern
afterwards with Joel Fleischmann and
Elizabeth Boras continues Joel I want to
talk a little bit with you about the 12
cases that you selected for the book
they're inspiring
they are big deeds by foundations the
Green Revolution the Flexner report why
don't you tell the tell us a little bit
about why you think these cases are
important and what you learned from them
I think that the that these cases are
important because they each of them
documents a major initiative by a
foundation that had signal benefits for
society you think about take the Green
Revolution case which really was the
Rockefeller Foundation and it's 25 year
pursuit of the discovery of new food
grains to change to transform a number
of developing world countries from food
deficit to food surplus countries that
they stuck at it for they stuck to it
for 25 years they hired the staff put it
on the staff of the Rockefeller
Foundation itself which is almond which
is rarely done by grant-making
foundations they put them out in the
field in Mexico they where they work
with Mexican agronomists and lo and
behold they came up with these new food
grains which ended up enabling not only
Mexico but Pakistan Bangladesh and India
to go from
food deficit - food surplus countries
it's been estimated by demographers that
that initiative by the Rockefeller
Foundation later joined in by the Ford
Foundation saved anywhere between a
billion and a billion and a half lives
did that impact that sixth or that's
impact uh or you mentioned the Flexner
report the flexible report documents
what one person supported by two
foundations the Carnegie Foundation for
the Advancement of teaching first
briefly and then the Rockefeller
Foundation did in transforming the
nature of American medicine
it was a prior to the Flexner report
American medicine was proprietary that
means that were the doctors owned their
hospitals they were they they were
doctors who subsisted on their
professional practice in teaching in
medical schools and it went from that to
one in which suddenly science is brought
in into medicine and all of the only
American medical school prior to the
flexin report that had anything like
that model was Johns Hopkins and they
and over a 30-year period the
Rockefeller Foundation then which is
where Flexner moved after doing the
report for the Carnegie Foundation with
advancement of teaching ended up
transforming the entire American Medical
School practice to the point where it's
now the envy of the world how about the
Soros foundation that's a more
contemporary example and it's a very
different kind of impact that an
individual in his philanthropy has had
it was very the Soros case deals with
the efforts that George Soros and his
foundations undertook to bring about the
downfall of communism in in Central and
Eastern Europe very big goal it's a very
big goal and you know I mean there were
many as is the case with all of these
examples one can't prove causation
because there are many different forces
at work but what one can say is sources
great idea was
forget the mobilisation of the creation
and mobilization of civil society
organizations in Central and Eastern
European countries empower them with
things like fax machines rudimentary
technology that they could use to
organize to get their message out to
build support and ultimately to bring
down the Berlin wall no you know it is
that's an extraordinary story it's an
example of how you can how you can take
an idea and carefully implement it with
the goal in mind of achieving a certain
consequence however George Soros himself
says that he operates kind of by the
seat of the pants I wonder if you see
scientific management principles in what
he's done well scientific management
enters as I say in the book the the the
judgement about what a foundation should
do in terms of the initiative really
almost always is a judgment that is
instinctive that's informed by a good
deal of knowledge but really is
basically instinctive it's the
implementation of it where the
scientific management comes in I mean
Andrew Carnegie another example in the
book the Carnegie's establishment of
what has now the largest or one of the
largest pension funds in the world I
mean this was Carnegie's idea and just
he said it's a shame that college
teachers have to worry about living
lives of penury when they retire and I
want to do something about that and he
so he started a pension fund which
required contributions from the
employing institution and from the
person who was who was going to receive
the pension and he started it with a
loan of 1111 million dollars so it that
was his idea it was an idea I should
tell you that there in the book i quote
john d rockefeller and his principal
philanthropic advisor is calling it a
damn fool idea and saying you know that
carnegie is a good example
millionairess menace so the truth is
that that it was an instinctive idea but
he was such a good judge of those ideas
so it's really now we have Tia crass and
now we have di double a craft which is
the interest which is the insurance
company that in that the pension company
which insures virtually all college
teachers professors foundation
professionals and many others in the
nonprofit sector so that's all it's all
attributable to this extraordinary
insight that Andrew Carnegie had in
which he resolved to to carry out but
that's the way he did things just he was
he had these ideas you know it's not
different you know his instinct of and
that led him to build it to to create
Carnegie steel corporation which was the
predecessor or one of the predecessors
of US Steel was the same kind of
instinct trying to understand how in
that in the case of Carnegie steel he
was going to make his fortune he saw
things about the steel industry and
about how you could how you could
aggregate different components of it to
build that whole enterprise and it's the
same thing and try to figure out a major
foundation initiative now I've heard
people say that one reason some of the
older grants were so big and so
grandiose and had such an impact is
because at that point in time of course
we had a rather small federal government
and the resources at the disposal of the
big foundations you know they sometimes
dwarfed what was available in the
government sector and so there was more
room for foundation initiatives to have
a tremendous impact and yet Soros is a
more recent example how would you how
would you respond to that I think that
all the all the growth of the government
means is that foundations work in
different areas or and sometimes in
cooperation with the government you
think about some of the major successes
of foundations have been to start things
that the government ultimately picked up
for example the Carnegie Commission on
public broadcasting this was an example
of something
nobody had been able to get it going
they've been talking about it for 20
years and the Carnegie Commission a
night from 1967 to 1968 managed to
create the Commission to 66 66 68
managed to create the Commission get
agreement on what the form should be
persuade Congress and the president to
create it and suddenly we have PBS and
NPR
as a consequence of this which was
initiated outside of government but
picked up by government and many of the
initiatives foundations end up getting
picked up by government but the truth is
a government is not doing things for
example in the area of public advocacy
which is a major initiative of
foundations when we were talking about
strategies earlier I meant to say that
one of them one of the most important
strategies that foundations employ is
figuring out how to change public policy
how to change and also figuring out how
to change the public's mind about things
you think about the grants that
foundations that a number of foundations
made for example to change environmental
policy starting in the in the 60s really
building on Rachel Carson's Silent
Spring but creating the all of the snape
uh blick interest law centers that focus
on environmental policy and which led to
the people who were in those centers
supported by the Ford Foundation and
other foundations were the people who
ended up writing the Clean Air Act the
Clean Water Act and so forth so a lot of
what foundations do are things that
government isn't doing but perhaps
should do and it's the role of the
foundations through the nonprofit's that
they end up supporting to enable the
public the government to pick up those
things there's no way that the
government really could engage very much
in the public advocacy arena because the
whole idea of public advocacy to change
public policy is to persuade the
government to do something that's not
doing or to do something differently
from what it's doing that could never be
done by the government right and yet
there are some critics who feel that
foundations are timid that they're not
taking on the big issue
big issues defined as poverty and
inequality and that with their resources
they should be doing more in areas like
those how would you respond to that I
think that's a bum rap my view is if you
look at the websites of the Ford
Foundation and the car and the
Rockefeller Foundation to take two
examples at this point they're both
focused on helping the less well-off
both in the US and abroad its asset
building it is it is microf microcredit
it's a variety of kinds of things you
know the Ford Foundation and the
Rockefeller Foundation you're both
spending in excess of 50% of their grant
making abroad and virtually all of that
is going to the developing world
countries so I don't I don't I mean if
you look at the cases in the book for
the cases that are cited in the book
they were done for the book many of
those cases focused explicitly on
benefiting the less well-off take risk
for example local initiatives support
corporation which is which is was
supported for 25 years by the Ford
Foundation it was the idea of one of the
one of the great American grant makers
Mike spirit off who is the vice
president for public affairs of the Ford
Foundation and who saw that one he
wondered why is it that financial
institutions don't provide don't give
money don't lend money to poor people to
build housing to start JA to start
businesses and so forth and he said I
think I know the reason he said I think
the reason is that the financial
institutions don't know which of the
possible borrowers are credit worthy and
which are not and he said I think that
we should create an organization which
will specialize in providing that
creditworthiness information to
financial institutions so with an
initial twenty five million dollar grant
from the Ford Foundation spirit I've
resigned his job at the foundation
became the president of the learning of
the local Institute initiative support
corporation leveraged over the course it
was going strong there's something like
60 to 70 little lists in that many
cities around the country and they've
they've leveraged somewhere now but
four and five billion dollars in private
financial institution money and
government money all of which benefits
poor people right which which brings up
another another issue and that is why do
you think that foundations aren't doing
more to lend their assets I mean they're
I think that's one of the pushes
recently and of course liske is a great
example of loans but there are many
billions as you said of assets what what
do you what is your take on that I think
that the reason that fent more
foundations I should start by saying
that that more foundations now are doing
more lending of assets than they than
they were before but it is it has grown
very slowly I mean from the time that
that the Ford Foundation articulated a
policy of program related investments
back in the 70s late 60s when Mack Bundy
was the president of the Ford Foundation
and into the 70s other foundations have
picked it up I mean the Herron
Foundation in New York is a small
foundation but does it but I'm but I
that many foundations are talking about
it and many others are beginning to do
it the the reluctance is that the
program related investments
mission-related investing is a tricky
kind of thing to do it's not as easy to
do as grant making because you've got
you're dealing with the competing use of
your resources if you're a foundation
your assets is to invest it for maximum
return and that involves really figuring
out how you do sophisticated asset
allocation in order to increase the the
the average return that you get to put
it in a simple in a simple point it is
very difficult you have to figure that
in it complicates the mix and the
conservative treasurer types money men
who oversee foundation investing of
their
assets are not enthusiastic about
program related investments
mission-related investing because the
returns are not as predictable as they
are when you've got discrete asset
classes and so it just complicates it is
that movement making headway yes it is
should it make headway yes it should but
it's been a very slow growth process
that this reminds me of an of another
issue and that is when foundations
invest in staff and effectiveness and
planning and evaluation all great things
that I think we both agree really should
be done it raises the cost of operating
the foundation and I want to talk about
some of your suggestions but it seemed
to me that Congress has been looking at
the administrative costs of foundations
the executive salaries is this a counter
force to the very call for effectiveness
and accountability that you've heralded
I don't think it is I think that the
congressional ire and public concern
have focused really on salaries
particularly of the higher officers of
the Foundation's perks first-class
travel and things of that nature
I haven't heard of any criticism about
the fact that the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation spends approximately 50
percent 15 for 15 percent excuse me 15%
of its grant making budget on evaluation
and many other foundations spend
significant amounts of their percentages
of their grant making on evaluation
which is a form of trying to ascertain
and increase the likelihood of
effectiveness so I don't I think that
while it is true that that you the more
you spend on things like transparency
and evaluation and communication with
the public you do raise your overhead
costs the fact is I don't think the
public objects to that it's not it's the
person it's the seemingly personal
benefit that occurs by the among the the
leaders of the foundations that is what
worries the public
and you know there's some foundations
the cause of the way they operate they
have higher administrative costs
foundations that run conference centers
for example now if the sophisticated
foundations have come to understand how
you can how you accurately allocate
their costs across a lot of their
program initiatives but some of others
haven't and that also complicates the
problem of makes it appear that they're
really spending more money on
administrative costs than they really
are absolutely I want to get to your
recommendations and your suggestions you
make some rather radical proposals I
think some people would call them
radical to enhance transparency you
talked about the lack of government
oversight the need for self-regulation
and failing that the need for a greater
government regulation tell me about the
proposal for more government oversight
the problem with government oversight at
this point is that it is that it is
almost non-existent the IRS has been
tasked with as far as the federal
government is concerned overseeing the
nonprofit sector that means saying that
they behave according to the law it
means catching people who are using the
nonprofit form for personal advantage
fraud things of that nature
nobody thinks that the IRS has the human
resource power at this point to to do
that job effectively and I suspect
though many people disagree with me I
suspect that the reason is that that
whatever the IRS does in the exempt
organization arena is tiny compared in
comparison with what it with the with
what it does in overseeing individual
and corporate taxes in terms of the
revenues it's just miniscule in the not
in the exempt organization arena you
know when they first passed the the
foundation tax in 1969 the the purpose
of that of the of the revenues generated
by that tax was for over
of the nonprofit sector it isn't that
that taxes generates depending on the
year it generates something between 300
and 600 or 700 million dollars a year
the budget from the exempt of the exempt
organization division of the IRS is
about 50 million dollars all of the rest
of that money coming from the foundation
tax which was intended by Congress to
you be used in overseeing the nonprofit
sector is going into the general
Treasury now I have no objection to
money going into the general Treasury
but I do have a very strong objection to
the to the fact that the nonprofit
sector doesn't have adequate government
oversight so I suggested picking up on a
proposal by Mark Owen who was himself
the director of the exempt organization
division of the IRS that a new form of
organization be created this related to
the IRS but independent of it a public
corporation that would and it would be a
nonprofit set up by Congress and
empowered with certain powers to enable
it to fulfill its function it would
leave certain responsibilities such as
the granting of the 501c3 status with
the IRS but it would delegate to this
new organization that would be modeled
on the National Association of
Securities Dealers the the actual
implementation of it to be sure that
there were ways in which adequate
oversight could be could be given you
would have a separate entity that would
not have to be involved with the budget
negotiations the IRS seems to make a lot
of sense to me what do you think the
obstacles are I think the obstacles are
there are many people who think that the
IRS should not and not shouldn't should
not be taken away from the IRS and of
course the hill committees with
jurisdiction over government agencies
would would prove to be an obstacle to
but I am firmly convinced that until we
have some other entity which is
designated and funded with sufficient
resources
to oversee the nonprofit sector we're
not going to be able to ensure minimal
compliance with the with the laws that
are on the books and that's really where
I the the primary function as far as I'm
concerned of government oversight is in
being sure that the laws are obeyed that
that criminals are not using the
nonprofit form to benefit themselves or
to defraud the public that's what I
that's what I want to see government
oversight do I want to with respect to
self-regulation which was the next point
that you raised um I want to see
foundations take go beyond the scope of
what is minimally required by the law
and adopt a higher set of standards for
ourselves and in in so that we can we
can aspirationally tried to do better
than among you mentioned a transparency
and accountability code could you what
would that do for us well it would it
would it would serve the purpose of
ensuring that that the public would know
what foundations are doing that people
who wanted to learn from what
foundations are doing could learn from
Foundation what they do because the
knowledge would be available the
blueprints about things that foundations
do would be available generally they're
not after all intellectual property that
foundations have any right to keep a
monopoly on and further it would the
existence of open communication by
people on the outside of what
foundations are doing and the
opportunity for criticism would make a
tremendous difference when you think
about all of the forces that are arrayed
to provide that external perspective on
for profits on corporations everything
from The Wall Street analysts to the
business reporters to the competitors
are always looking to acquire a company
to the shareholders who can vote
management in and out so they don't do
it very often all of those things we
have nothing like that in the nonprofit
sector as a whole of
nonprofit organizations such as students
at universities faculty alumni at
universities patients and hospitals
doctors and hospitals but foundations
have none and it is really important it
seems to me that we build in those
external build into the into the way in
which foundations are governed the those
external perspectives on what they do we
both know that foundations are very
independent they really value their
independence and that it's very hard to
get them to agree on something like a
code of transparency and accountability
I was at the Council on Foundations when
they tried to instill principles and
practices now it did pass but it was
meant multi-year long conversation and
some foundations ultimately left the
Council on Foundations what makes you
think that foundations could come around
or do you think foundations could come
around to a code of transparency that
would really have some teeth and that
would be accepted by the field I think
that foundations can come around and I
think that they will come around in part
because the idea of public public and
public related institutions being
transparent was a very new thing when
the council went through that exercise
it now is not a new thing it is taken
for granted we have a Freedom of
Information Act in federal government
many states have Freedom of Information
acts the notion is that that public
business is public business and it ought
to be open at least certain kinds of
information ought to be open to the
public so I think that there is a
momentum to the idea of transparency
which I believe is beginning to move
foundations that's precisely why I think
the Wallace Foundation and the and the
Packard Foundation have decided to put
bring in independent consultants and
free them to publish whatever they want
to publish it's why the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation is now putting up its
assessments or at least some of its
assessments on their website I think
that's going to grow and the webs of the
existence of websites is making a
tremendous differ
I think so too I'd like to ask you a
little bit about this Foundation Freedom
of Information Act you say failing all
else maybe we need to have greater
government regulation and I know you
carefully qualify it but I'd like people
to understand what would a Foundation
Freedom of Information Act do it would
guarantee to whom whoever ended up being
having the right to bring a suit or or
articulate a request some kinds of
information that information that
foundations generate it might for
example enable persons to get copies of
assessments there was a very plaintive
letter for example in the in education
wing week last fall Oh in the summertime
from the head of the education
leadership program at Brooklyn College
in which he talked about the fact that
when when when that college works with
public school systems in various
projects they run in trying to reform
education that they can get the
information generated the evaluative and
from the evaluations generated under
those programs because they're
government documents but when a
foundation and the he mentioned
particularly the Gates Foundation when
the Gates Foundation supported an
initiative in which they were involved
the Gates Foundation basically had
proprietary control over the over the
evaluative documents and they couldn't
get control of him and so the point is
you know particularly where foundations
are working with public institutions
there is some rationale for having
individuals on the outside of the
foundation have access to those and I
want to underscore what I said earlier I
am NOT proposing at this point a Freedom
of Information Act for foundations I
don't want government to get involved as
long as I think there is the possibility
that foundations can take the initiative
themselves in making in becoming more
transparent and providing that
information I hope that they will do
that
and I only offered the idea of the credo
of the Freedom of Information Act has
sort of a last-ditch effort if they
don't I think that's a great place to to
end our conversation and I want to thank
you very very much for this conversation
this opportunity to speak with you about
your book I think it really is an
important book and I hope my goal would
be for lots of people to read it and
discuss it